يقول الرئيس زيلينسكي إن الحرب
تعود تدريجياً إلى روسيا وأن
الضربات على أراضيها أصبحت
حتمية الآن بعد أن
اتهم الكرملين أوكرانيا بشن
هجوم بطائرة بدون طيار في موسكو يوم الأحد، وتقول روسيا
إنها اعترضت ثلاث مركبات بدون طيار،
ولكن كما ترون في الفيديو على الأقل
اصطدمت إحداها بمركز أعمال، وقد
حدث ذلك بعد أيام من تحذير روسيا من
أنها تحتفظ بالحق في اتخاذ
إجراءات صارمة ردًا على الهجمات التي تقع على
أراضيها بما في ذلك الهجوم الذي وقع في
الجنوب الغربي،
وفي وقت سابق تحدثت مع اللواء المتقاعد
بالجيش الأسترالي ميك رايان،
وهو ضابط سابق في الجيش الأسترالي.  سألته أنا والقائد في
كلية الدفاع الأسترالية عما إذا كانت
هذه الهجمات الأخيرة في روسيا يمكن أن تكون
استراتيجية رابحة لأوكرانيا، هذا
ما قاله وهو
يبكي وهو يرد على روسيا، أعني أن
هناك ضرورة سياسية
للرئيس زيلينسكي للرد بعد
هذه الضربات الروسية الرهيبة على  أوديسا
في المواقع الثقافية التاريخية ومواقع تصدير الحبوب
ولكن هناك أيضًا معلومات
حتمية مفادها أن أوكرانيا تريد نقل
الحرب إلى الشعب الروسي
وتقول إن هذه ليست عملية عسكرية خاصة
تقتصر على أوكرانيا، إنها
حرب أنت جزء منها،
فكيف  هل تتوقع أن ترد روسيا
عسكريًا على هذه الهجمات على أراضيها
جيدًا؟ أعتقد أننا سنرى روسيا ترد
مرة أخرى بمزيد من الهجمات بالطائرات بدون طيار والصواريخ،
لكن هذا يتساوى إلى حد كبير مع
مسار الروس في هذه الحرب،
وسيواصلون القيام بذلك و  سيستمرون في
توجيه الاتهامات بأن هذا
الهجوم المضاد الذي
يقوم به الأوكرانيون لاستعادة
أراضيهم يمنع السلام.
كانت المقدمة من روسيا
وما هو التأثير الذي قد تحدثه هذه
الهجمات الأوكرانية على روسيا على بعض
الدول الغربية التي ترسل حاليًا
مساعدات عسكرية إلى أوكرانيا
حسنًا، طوال فترة الحرب،
قام الأوكرانيون بتوسيع نطاق وصولهم تدريجيًا في
هذا النوع من الضربات، فقد رأيناهم في
قاعدة إينغلس الجوية، وشاهدنا
ضربات على سيفاستوبول، والآن ثلاث
هجمات على موسكو في هذا الوقت،
لا أفهم أن الغرب  تشعر الدول
بالقلق بشأن هذه
الضربات الموجهة للغاية، فهي لا تقتل
مدنيين روس، لكن بالتأكيد قد
ينظر البعض إلى هذا كسبب
محتمل لعدم إعطاء أوكرانيا ضربات جوية
إذا كان هذا هو الحال فستكون مأساة.